[Music]
in lucky or unlucky news pack lucky
submitted by Schweddy Balls a man found
a nude burglar asleep in his bed tie let
me say hi or girl that's that's
important no matter what yeah because
like you're on such a high you rob the
house you already hide from that and you
got a jack off and get naked tell me I'm
a sexist all you want but if I found a
naked woman burglar in my bed that's not
that that's not scary at all that's kind
of that's like a nice present period a
no period my sheets when we're picturing
a woman we're picturing like a model
yeah like a beautiful model like not
Charlize Theron in monster I don't need
her to be beautiful okay change from a
model to a really a big walrus yeah it's
a wide berth you guys think about how
crazy this [ __ ] is though in your in
your house bite that [ __ ] off
like what do you think she's gonna do
man alright I bet you she's such a mean
dick yes man in NorCal oh close by
mm-hmm
Anderson I don't know it's like we're at
a stand-up show right now Anderson
California daddy oh is that where the
Anderson split pea soup is that maybe
you know that they have they have they
have billboards all over the five
freeway when you're when you're driving
oh I know what you're talking about yeah
little German thing we're like yeah it's
got that little windmill thing boy you
gotta pull off the road here for some
split pieces
actually sold me one a good brand they
sold me I was like I had to go I got the
field there and then I found out it was
baby cow you didn't know it was baby
girl oh I just thought it was fancy meat
yeah it's sad like veal like the whole
thing with God they're delicious it's
just good right it's like a lamb dude
it's like oh [ __ ] this is so sad yeah I
gotta feel so bad for the baby cow but
I'm not gonna deny that it's not delish
it's delicious it's delicious
that's the thing the pea soup is baby
cow no I ordered the veal there and I
got the split pea soup I was just eating
the baby grown one why would they stop
it what it is soft what you're paying
for brother yeah so cute unidentified
man told police that this all started
the way he found this naked stranger in
his Helmand it all started when he got
home he saw that there was a utility
knife that he had seen inside his home
previously this utility knife was laying
on the porch oh no he went inside he
found a sandwich with a fight taken oh
just one bite and oh baby was nasty
damn lazy [ __ ] criminals like a dude
so far sandwich fell asleep in the bed
definitely masturbated for sure a pack
of cigarettes was missing and an empty
beer bottle deftly jacked off and he
noticed that someone had recently taken
a shower in the bathroom and that there
come on there were clothes just strewn
about and when he checked his computer
they cleared the Internet I know
everything yes then that's a new in his
bedroom and he found a woman sleeping
there nice my dude not bad not a bad day
[ __ ] do they [ __ ] what they write so
then he ended up calling 9-1-1
she was busted
I don't have photos of anyone I don't
have memes well it might mine she's
[ __ ] hot it she's so hot for me she
took a peek before he call now on one
yeah it must been busted yeah yeah so he
woke her up called 9-1-1 and while he
was talking on the phone with the police
the woman got dressed and then she ended
up wandering out on the front porch she
sat down in a chair and just pretty much
waited for police to get there in a
register oh she was hot
Michelle 33 years old not that they keep
it tight I tell you what she ended up
getting arrested and she ended she kept
the pack of cigarettes when she was
arrested the police let her go again
what's her name
Michelle Watkins oh she sounds a hot man
yeah she sounds like a model that had a
crazy night in Vegas lost her way home
thought you know that was her house and
she just wanted to stay keep the party
going so she drank and smoked some
cigarettes
nice let's see I bet you she's hot is
she naked see if you'd call the cops
guys let's say we'll go down the line we
did you call the cops would you call the
cop I call the cops yeah I call the
fools yeah she looks crazy like although
I will say this the mug shot is always
the worst right she can be cute she
might she slept and got off the meth
yeah she might be pretty good you make
him work no I call a [ __ ] SWAT team
they're gonna chop something off
she would make someone punched her in
the face with me boy I call the bomb
squad
come on percent I haven't seen a [ __ ]
robot it up to the bed it wasn't what I
was expecting but that's not the worst
thing to find it exactly there's way
worse to be found in your house you
always looking at the on the bright side
of things anything me I need me more
like you yeah I need to be way more like
you positive positive I mean it could
have been a you know football player but
naked as females what would you feel
that happened to you good woman yeah
another female oh my go crazy right now
you'll pull it by the hair she has money
that's your [ __ ] too right
let's hear it engage just cuddle with
her you have to do anything she showered
for crying out loud
yes very clean soap kills diseases smoke
a pack of cigarettes and some she
doesn't have the flu she got everything
we're saying she's Queen she's fine here
we come hope cases not walking the [ __ ]
I can't believe this woman that's crazy
a trap doesn't mean much anymore nobody
knows anyways she ended up being jailed
because she didn't have the $25,000
and she was not a lot of people do
she was arrested on suspicion of
residential burglary petty theft and
possession of stolen property
and because of the fact that she had the
cigarettes on her creating male
fantasies wow what a crime when I got a
couple ready keeping the city dude how'd
she get it she wedged the door with that
knife I feel like the guy just didn't
lock his door yeah I just walked in goes
to the door opens it salsa night
what's my juice this guy's probably like
you know in his 30s or something but you
changed this age like you make this like
a fifteen-year-old boy okay and it's
like [ __ ] a John Hughes movie I think
he comes on when he's like it's like
[ __ ] weird science like he created a
woman and she's in his bed thank you you
walked into your home saw this what
would you do I would I would talk like
I'm gonna [ __ ] beat it up but that'd
probably be too scared to do anything I
don't get my mom 100% I would I would be
straight-up masturbating outside the
door so I could have a clear head clear
I'll talk a huge game to my friends oh
like oh my god this woman's on my bed
and I'm like maybe I should it mmm but I
might too scared 100% hundreds oh yeah
you document that it's fair leader I'm
saying that outside masturbation gives
you a clear head and because you're
young you can actually do it again so
I'm good
and all my friends would be like you
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] you doing [ __ ]
did I would have thought dear for sure
no you wouldn't know everybody would
have had cold feet everybody 15 years
old yeah yeah but now you would it
absolutely you just said you were called
by now what if she woke up and she
wanted to suck your dick
are you aware this is a crazy fantasy
just go mid god that would never happen
okay I feel like if I walked in there
I'll be like is Jesus real good Santa is
Santa like give me that's a gift what if
I was single yeah there was a naked girl
in the bed
it doesn't have to be her but a naked
girl it could be you yeah it could be
okay but that's not really a surprise
I'm I'll be tripping I'll be like just
real yeah is this is their [ __ ]
hitting cameras like am I supposed to
[ __ ] like what's happening you know am I
supposed to [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't know
what to do I just assumed that she's
been a stalker of mine and she's been
really wanting my days and I would just
wake her up with a surprise a big
[ __ ] boner
what if she's a but then it'll be raped
because I didn't know it was a I would
think it was a fan that was like wanting
some dick fans out there Jolie oh no no
no hey you were a fan
we're gonna talk later Steve you're like
I'm the only fan who gets the [ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
yeah she's she's got respect I had to
fly to me and she offered me barbecue
first yeah okay that's very enticing
nudes first and then barbecue it yeah
she said why don't you come over for
some barbecue and sex and I said the two
most favorite things my world you are my
type of woman you matter where you but
that plane ticket
anyways off of me pretty fun subject hey
guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]